travailler la terre de la réunion et
laisser le robot aspirateur faire son
oeuvre
c'est avec cet art en mouvement éphémère
que les théâtres ouvrent leurs portes
pour une nouvelle saison février juillet
2016 le principe c'est que je cherche
des particules ultime de dégradation de
très petites particules
tout est filtré eto'o et on obtient en
fait des partis qui sont très fines et
qui ont du coup une texture est une
couleur bien différente une surface
couverte d'une mosaïque de différents
minéraux mais tous issus de la terre
réunionnaise c'est sans doute cela qui
caractérise une partie de la
programmation des théâtres pour ce début
de saison
elle affiche un peu d'eau unis si aig de
money sur deux hors commerce affaire
c'est que moi je peux pas faire une
progression si j'en suis pas fier donc
là encore une fois je suis très très
très fier cette programmation qui fait
encore la fois la part belle aux
artistes qui ont fait ce que c'est que
la réunion avec danyel waro avec
frédéric joron et puis la nouvelle
génération comme tricot de peau comme
une copie enfin d'un état comme ça donc
toujours pareil la moitié de
propositions réunionnaises et puis
d'autres de l'extérieur des petites
nouveautés peut-être c'est le festival
de l'humour cette année avec là aussi
encore une fois juste équilibre entre la
réunion et l'extérieur
et puis aussi l'entrée de la ligue
d'improvisation dans sa version chant
avec les verticaux et la version plus
théâtrale avec la compagnie la bagasse
chargé de la culture profiter de cette
rentrée pour former un ensemble du monde
culturel
me rilov alors je souhaite à tous les
acteurs de parsys et les professionnels
de la nature le formateur médiateur
créative ouverture avec emmanuel noble
et qui s'inspire d'un roman celui de
maylis de kerangal réparer des vivants
qui raconte l'itinéraire d'un corps
celui de simon 19 ans victime d'un
accident mortel
christian perdu le contrôle du van et je
serai un accident marianne et sean les
parents de simon se précipitèrent alors
à l'hôpital
il parlait à thomas rémiges un médecin
qui leur dit que six mois était mort
mais qu'il pouvait donner ses organes
roméo et juliette shakespeare
l'événement de l'année pour les amateurs
de danse le ballet preview cage
réinvente la mort tragique on met en
scène 24 danseurs mêlant n'est pas de
classique à des techniques très
contemporaine les roms deviennent ville
du futur en février total des festivals
jeunes mais la zone qu'higuain
émergentes si de nos papilles tee en
compagnie d'acteurs le théâtre sous les
arbres qui revisite roméo juliette qui
devient pour l'occasion
juliette et roméo côté musique octobre
le duo féminin de la nouvelle sonne du
magnolia sera du côté des badamiers en
mars benjam retrouve ses racines après
avoir erré du côté du ragga ou encore de
la dancehall
il nous invite un calot badia où théâtre
en plein air le samedi 12 mars
m
la même scène qui accueillera le week
end de nay tour darron duo français qui
s'inspire de l'électronique et des
années 80 cela donnait une pop
synthétique qui sera exceptionnellement
à la réunion le vendredi 18 mars
la nuit du court la 9e nuit des
virtuoses total jazz les chiens de
navarre nicolas givran autour de
rendez-vous éclectique à découvrir ou
redécouvrir pour certains fans
et puis une nouveauté cette année le
festival de l'humour avec des humoristes
d'ici et d'ailleurs pour en citer
quelques-uns eric fleurissent pour la
réunion et olivier de benoist pour cette
soif d'or à ne pas rater le 21 mai le
maître du maloya sera sur la scène du
théâtre avec tricot tu peux batarsité du
nombre d'albums de danyel waro et
quelques invités sous le ciel étoilé de
saint gilles le maloya prendra là toute
sa dimension
l'histoire enfin côté de notre match on
contrôle tout le monde fait rire les
opprimés vsat et d'épidémiologie et la
légende vivante de ce que la réunion a
produit en mettre de la poésie
frédéric ils auront fête ses 30 ans de
carrière et des mélodies magnifiques
reprise par toutes les générations ce
sera le samedi 2 juillet au théâtre
plein air
les finnois
on va
et puis quand même
puis 1
si un des modèles silence
direct par le
du pur et dur mais aussi de la douceur
et de la nostalgie d'un temps avec les
dalons carrousel et quelques pointures
qui viendront reprendre des standards tu
remarqué nos ballerines et c'est de
cette trempe qu'est la petite dernière
qui veut mettre son grain de sel dans
l'univers musical réunionnais teen pop y
c'est un mélange de fraîcheur de joie de
vivre de bonheur on veut y goûter encore
et encore c'est du côté de la scène
madame nickel fera chanter la vie le
vendredi 25